Movies have become so reliant on digital
effects that their original footage
is often completely unrecognizable
from what you see on screen. Here's
what these movies really looked like
before the special effects were added.
Leading man Leonardo DiCaprio and director
Alejandro G. Iñárritu weren't the only ones
to gain recognition for their work on 2015's
The Revenant. From riding a horse off a cliff
to an epic bear attack, ILM, the digital
team behind the film's special effects,
had their work cut out for them.
The true hero of this film,
though, was Glenn Enniss, the 6'4''
stuntman who played the iconic bear.
"It was hard on the body. So, you know,
on your hands and feet, picking
someone up, throwing them around."
Ennis also admitted that DiCaprio was a
pretty intense co-star. The A-lister's
agony was so believable that Ennis
thought he was actually hurting him.
Despite failing to recoup its $110 million
budget, nobody could deny that 2016's Passengers
looked great. Director Morten Tyldum wanted to
keep the visual effects as subtle as possible.
Effects company MPC was behind many of the
film's iconic shots, including a beautiful,
zero-gravity water sequence. However,
though special effects may be accessible,
they certainly aren't cheap. MPC's visual
effects supervisor Pete Dionne told Art of VFX:
"[Morten's] aesthetic is definitely biased
towards invisible effects, and where they
couldn't be invisible by nature, to keep them
restrained and to never distract from the drama."
Warner Bros. maxed out their $250 million
budget for Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice,
and although the film made tons of money,
critics still weren't impressed. Director
Zack Snyder received a lot of flack, but
he claimed that he and his effects team
actually went out of their way to pay homage
to the source material. Take Superman's cape,
for instance. VFX supervisor
Bryan Hirota told Art of VFX:
"[It] had to act and feel natural, but on the
other hand behave in an art-directed way and
create appealing shapes that remind
the viewer of the original comics."
That may sound like a nice detail, but it's a
safe bet that everyone was too busy trying to
spot actor Henry Cavill's CGI-erased moustache
in Justice League to go back and notice.
The Hunger Games franchise split
its final book into two movies,
and most fans agree that the second was far
more exciting than the first. VFX supervisor
Charles Gibson described Mockingjay - Part 2
as a war film with massive setpieces, saying:
"We had to enhance battle action
and create believable environments
that would hold up for extended coverage."
Working closely with production
designer Phil Messina,
Gibson agreed on a mix of shooting on
location and building digital sets,
saying that Messina's input on the project
and his design approach were invaluable.
South Korean director Bong Joon-ho turned
countless Netflix users vegan in 2017 with
Okja, the touching story of a girl and her
super-pig. VFX supervisor Erik-Jan de Boer
explained that the success of the film hinged
on whether the audience believed that Okja,
a genetically engineered pig, was real.
As he explained to No Film School,
"The only way that people are really going
to believe Mija and Okja and their little pet
friendship is if we have a lot of contact,
and if that contact is truly believable."
In order to achieve this physical contact, the VFX
team created a range of foam props for young star
Ahn Seo-hyun to interact with, including a full
body suit for the most intimate interactions.
Fortunately, the effort paid off, as Okja struck
a chord with both viewers and critics alike.
The sequel to Ridley Scott's seminal sci-fi
classic Blade Runner was a long time coming,
and the VFX team felt the weight
of the '80s cult classic on
their shoulders. Overall visual effects
supervisor John Nelson told Art of VFX,
"Any fan of science fiction or cinema has a great
deal of reverence for the original
Blade Runner, myself included."
Blade Runner 2049's cityscapes, in particular,
were a huge job, and multiple VFX companies were
hired to craft this world in miniature. While the
film fell below box office expectations, it did at
least manage to capture the neon-noir feeling that
resonated with fans of the original so strongly.
Before Blade Runner 2049, Denis Villeneuve
directed a sci-fi outing that was a little
more grounded in reality. 2016's
Arrival follows a linguist and a
physicist as they attempt to communicate
with an alien species. The VFX style was
the polar opposite of the Blade Runner
sequel, seeming drab and washed-out in
comparison. VFX supervisor and regular
collaborator Louis Morin told VFXblog,
"[Villeneuve] wanted nothing to
do with any kind of sci-fi movie
that we've been seeing recently from
Hollywood. . . . he just wanted this
movie to feel so real and so boring in
so many ways, like, ordinary looking."
Louis then talked about a
cold, cloudy day in Montreal,
where Villeneuve explained that this
was what he wanted Arrival to look like.
Considering how grey and drab the film
looked, it's safe to say he nailed it.
Alex Garland's indie sci-fi drama Ex Machina
beat out many big-budget films to win the Best
Achievement in Visual Effects Oscar in 2016.
According to VFX supervisor Andrew Whitehurst,
the shoot was so well-organized and efficient
that they had extra cash to spend on making Ava,
the AI, look amazing. He explained that the
initial budget would have only allowed them
to animate Ava's torso and limbs, and that the
extra money let them animate her head and neck
as well. Garland also wanted to make sure Ava had
romantic appeal. Costume designer Sammy Sheldon
Differ explained that her suit, which left little
to the imagination, was a massive group effort.
Zack Snyder's 300 made heavy use of CGI, and
the technology used to create it had advanced
immensely by the time its sequel, Rise of
an Empire, came around. Which, of course,
meant squeezing every ounce of that tech into
the movie. Director Noam Murro told Forbes:
"It's amazing how the tools available eight years
later continue to develop. A major difference is
CGI and the ability to create things in post that
are convincing and complex and three-dimensional.
The idea of creating a water movie without
a drop of water on the set is remarkable."
The filmmaker also revealed they relied on
some of the same techniques used in the
Oscar-winning CGI blockbuster Gravity.
Neill Blomkamp's follow-up to his acclaimed
debut District 9 didn't exactly go as planned,
despite the star power of Matt Damon.
The blockbuster sci-fi cost a whopping
$115 million to make, but only returned
$93 million at the domestic box office.
But while Blomkamp took full
responsibility for the film's failings,
the South African director didn't have any
complaints about the special effects team,
which had to put together over three times as
many VFX shots as they had for District 9.
When Steven Spielberg decided to adapt
Michael Crichton's novel Jurassic Park,
CGI as we know it today didn't
really exist. Spielberg brought
on Industrial Light and Magic and
tasked them with creating living,
breathing dinosaurs using computer-generated
graphics, and their efforts proved revolutionary.
Of course, it wasn't just CGI that brought the
inhabitants of Jurassic Park to life. There were
a number of practical effects used too, and ILM
mixed it up in the same way for Jurassic World.
The fourth film in the franchise used detailed
white casts of dinosaur heads that would later
be layered with CGI for close-up shots, and
they used actors in motion capture suits
to make sure their movement seemed real. VFX
supervisor Tim Alexander told Below the Line:
"It gave us a new natural look for the
animation. We ended up casting a person
to give us a consistency in the performance. There
were individual people being that raptor. We had
suits that they would put on with a tail."
When George Miller returned to the world of
Mad Max with his critically acclaimed Fury
Road in 2015, audiences were blown away by
the sequel's frenetic pace and visceral
action—much of which was achieved through
the hard work of inventive mechanics who built
the vehicles used in the movie from scratch.
The chase scenes were all shot for real,
but the final product wouldn't have looked
anywhere near as eye-popping if it weren't for
the VFX team. Led by supervisor Andrew Jackson,
hundreds of CGI artists enhanced
over 2000 shots in Fury Road,
from adding characters to
creating an epic toxic storm.
When Earth's Mightiest Heroes teamed up on the big
screen in 2012, the stakes were high for Marvel
Studios and their team of visual effects artists.
Jeff White, the film's VFX supervisor, told MTV:
"With Avengers, there were so many things
to get right. We created a lot of New York
City for the film and needed to build flying
shots of Iron Man all from photography. We
had to build a new Iron Man suit—the Mark
VII—and Stark Tower. We had to build the
alien race. When you add all of those things
up, there are quite a few challenges there."
Green screens were used during most of the
film's action sequences, so the cast spent
a good chunk of time reacting to invisible
threats and taking cover from fake explosions.
The biggest hurdle they faced was inserting the
Hulk into group situations. White explained:
"We wanted it to feel very natural
when he's sitting in that circle of
Avengers. We spent a lot of time working
on his skin and his hair and his teeth,
just to make sure that all
of that was believable."
To create the illusion of flight, Richard Donner's
Superman employed wire rigs to hang leading
man Christopher Reeve in front of different
projected backgrounds. The film is a classic,
and the effects looked great in the
'70s, but watching it today it feels
as though you're flying with Superman as
opposed to him flying past you—something
Man of Steel director Zack Snyder wanted to
avoid when he set out to make Superman soar.
Snyder decided to use a handheld approach
to filming Clark's flying scenes,
which meant adding in most of the effects
in post. Wire rigs and gimbals were used
to suspend Henry Cavill in front of green
screens, and the CGI team did the rest.
When the first Iron Man movie dropped in 2008,
director Jon Favreau wasn't known for CGI-heavy
features, but advances in technology
had convinced him to change his stance.
"I've always skewed away from using visual
effects whenever possible. That being said,
in the last few years there's been
a lot of wonderful visual effects
movies where it's beginning to
become seamless even to me."
Favreau returned for the sequel, but Shane Black
took the reins for Iron Man 3, which contained
some of the most challenging visual effects yet.
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige explained:
"We wanted the ability to be able to suit up
anywhere, anyhow, without a giant gantry."
The answer was having Tony Stark design outlets
he injects just below the skin, not unlike the
comics, allowing him to call the Iron Man
suit from anywhere. To pull off the effect,
each individual piece had to be digitally added
to Robert Downey Jr.'s body after the fact.
Years of gymnastics training really paid off for
Tom Holland on the set of Spider-Man: Homecoming,
the character's eagerly anticipated introduction
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe. Even with the
advances in CGI in recent years, it helps to
have an actor who feels comfortable jumping
around in tights and doesn't mind hanging around
on wires all day long. This was the case with
the film's Washington Monument scene—but while
that was indeed Holland under the Spidey mask,
the monument itself was a fake,
erected on a studio sound stage.
"We couldn't film at the real Washington
Monument, but we built very impressive,
very large chunks of the monument for filming."
Holland got up the structure
with the aid of a wire rig,
though even with his background it
was far from a walk in the park.
"We did two weeks and every single shot was
upside down. My head just took a pounding
from all the blood that was rushing to it."
The CGI Jon Favreau used for Iron Man was
nothing compared to what he did for his 2016
live-action adaptation of The Jungle Book. To
create an entire jungle around a human
actor, they needed to pull out all the
stops. The lighting was particularly
difficult. The director explained:
"It's very hard to fake light and shadow.
So everything became about using panels
of LEDs to project light so if we had
the kid bowing before the elephants,
you have panels where we actually
would pre-animate the elephants
and they would cast the shadows on
the kid in the exact right way."
This meant that 12-year-old star Neel Sethi had
to imagine the animals he was interacting with,
though Favreau was on hand to make the experience
as real as possible for the young actor via
puppets and actors in blue suits.
Paul Verhoeven's RoboCop got the most
out of the special effects available in
'80s, using a combination of stop-motion
and prosthetic builds to create a movie
that was disturbingly realistic at times.
In the 2014 reboot, Murphy gets his injuries
in an explosion that was created digitally,
but the suit he dons afterward was actually real.
"And it was a philosophy from the start that
we were going to have a head-to-toe suit."
The challenge was building a suit that was mobile
and easy for the digital department to add onto.
Ridley Scott is no stranger to special
effects, but creating the red planet
onscreen for The Martian may have been
his biggest challenge as a director.
While some practical effects were used, a
huge amount of digital work was required to
give The Martian Scott's desired look. VFX
supervisor Anders Langlands told Gizmodo:
"[Ridley Scott] is famous for doing
his little sketches which are sort
of really cool Ridley-grams.
We'd ask 'What do you want
the background mountains to look like in
this shot?' And he'd sketch out a little
diagram of what they wanted. So you just
literally match that and he'd be happy."
A lot of time was spent finding the right hue for
the skies and arid landscapes of Mars, though in
the end it was a simple thing that caused the
VFX team the most problems: the helmet visors.
"But of course glass visors would reflect the crew
and the lights and the sound stage.
So all the helmet visors you see in the film are actually added in digitally."
David Ayer's anti-hero
ensemble Suicide Squad definitely had its flaws,
but few of those were the fault of the many visual
effects houses—18 companies in total—that
worked tirelessly on it. Imageworks were the
ones who handled the Squad's final battle
with Enchantress, and the movie's villain
proved to be a huge challenge, according to VFX
supervisor Mark Breakspear. He told ARTofVFX:
"Enchantress was a unique challenge as the
actress had been shot without a costume as we
had to add it in later to allow it to behave in
a way that normal cloth or materials couldn't."
Breakspear later told AWN that of the 300 shots
they enhanced for the film's third act, dealing
with the Enchantress' tattoos proved the most
difficult. "That was amazingly tricky to make sure
it looked like skin, but also had the translucency
that we needed to see the sub-surface tattoos."
Watching Martin Scorsese's ode to excess The Wolf
of Wall Street, the only scenes that stick out as
being possibly computer-generated are the one
during which Jordan Belfort's yacht sinks and
the one when a lion wanders freely through his
office. But a visual effects reel released by
Brainstorm Digital revealed that some of the most
basic shots in the movie were rendered with CGI.
From sun loungers to tennis courts, Brainstorm
made plenty of subtle touches to bring the film
in line with the director's vision. VFX
producer Mark Russell told Digital Arts:
"Working with Martin Scorsese,
everything is about propelling
a story forward and contributing to
the film. I feel that with his movies,
there's a kind of stylized realism to
them that we have to integrate with."
The amount of destruction on show in this
Dwayne Johnson-led blockbuster definitely
doesn't come cheap, but San Andreas actually
cost a lot less to make than many of the big
natural disaster flicks that came before it.
According to Variety, the production budget was
only $114 million—roughly half the amount needed
to bring Roland Emmerich's 2012 to the big screen.
The film's visual effects
supervisor, Colin Strause,
was able to keep costs down by employing
practical solutions to problems that most
visual effects companies would solve with
only computers today. As he explained it:
"You can make a $100 million movie
look like a $200 million movie. You
can make movies way smarter. CG for
the sake of CG is always a mistake."
Effects studio Weta Digital changed the game
when they helped reboot Planet of the Apes
with a new trilogy of prequels, beginning with
2011's Rise of the Planet of the Apes. Producer
Dylan Clark had a special amount of praise for
Andy Serkis. The industry's top performance
capture artist shone as protagonist Caesar,
redefining screen acting in the digital age.
"Andy Serkis is unlike any other
actor. He can inhabit characters
that don't speak and emote in ways
that you don't really see often."
Fox campaigned for Serkis
to get an Oscar nomination,
but the call from the Academy never came,
much to the actor's frustration. After the
release of 2017's War of the Planet
of the Apes, Serkis told Independent:
"The awarding bodies should not
discriminate about this being
different. The visual effects render the
character, just like putting on makeup,
except here it happens after the fact.
It's digital makeup, if you will."
Bringing J.K. Rowling's Wizarding World to life
was only ever going to be possible with the help
of CGI, and the films made increasingly good use
of visual effects with each installment. While
early CGI hasn't aged well, the quality of digital
imagery from Goblet of Fire onward still holds up.
The VFX team had to up their game for the fourth
film in the series, as it marked the return of
Lord Voldemort. Paul Franklin, the VFX supervisor
for Order of the Phoenix and Half-Blood Prince,
revealed that creating Voldemort's nose was
a mammoth task. Franklin told Radio Times:
"There's this idea that we put the
shots through the computer and it
just vanished off [his] face. [...] [His
nose] had to be painstakingly edited out,
frame by frame, over the whole film.
And then the snake slits had to be
added and tracked very carefully using
dots put on his face for reference."
That's a lot of work for a couple nose slits,
but Voldemort just wouldn't
have been the same without them.
"Nothing's too good for James Potter."
Filming this tale of a boy stranded at sea
with a Bengal tiger came with a number of
obstacles—but the biggest one wasn't the tiger,
it was the water. Director Ang Lee explained:
"I knew that to make it work with 3D, water
had to become a character itself. I've never
seen realistic water scenes in movies
because water hits one side of a tank
wall and bounces back like it would in a
bathtub, but we needed to make it work."
That's not to say that the tiger was easy to
create, either. Scenes in which Pi interacts
with the deadly animal were done using a crude
puppet. The rest of it had to come from CGI.
Tim Burton was creating stunning visual
effects long before relying heavily on CGI,
using a combination of practical techniques to
bring his vision to the screen. The former Disney
artist used stop-motion animation, miniatures and
puppetry to great effect in his earlier works,
though when the opportunity to direct his own
version of Alice In Wonderland came along,
he soon realized that he couldn't do it
without leaning heavily on digital wizardry.
This meant that all the stars of the
movie had to do the bulk of their acting
in front of green screens. According to
visual effects supervisor Ken Ralston,
it was a challenge for the whole team.
"The green screen color, after long periods of
time, seems to create a certain aggravation and
irritation after staring at it for a long
period. It is effective for compositing,
but visually and psychologically exhausting to be
surrounded by it for extended periods of time."
When Disney first announced their intention
to remake a number of their beloved animated
classics in live action format, the title
that raised the most eyebrows was Beauty
and the Beast. A film in which the majority
of the supporting characters are animated
household objects was always going to rely on
CGI, though director Bill Condon has never liked
digital effects and actively avoided using
them wherever possible. He told IndieWire:
"It was important to make everything that could
be real, real. I'm not a big fan of CG movies.
The idea is to feel grounded in a world and not
be distracted by things that felt like additions."
Unfortunately for the actor portraying the Beast,
Dan Stevens, it was motion capture all the way,
plus some stilts to get him to the right height.
"It wasn't easy on stilts, heh heh."
Stevens spoke to both Andy Serkis and
Mark Ruffalo about their experiences
in motion capture roles, and their
feedback left him sweating. He added:
"I think I was mildly terrified. But
that's really, generally what drives
a lot of my decisions these days, is
calibrating the right amount of terror."
Nothing like a Disney movie to
get that fear meter up, right?
Christopher Nolan is notorious for using
real-life effects as much as possible,
and most of the big effects in The
Dark Knight were done on-camera.
"The only visual effect involved in that scene was
to remove the ram that they
had built inside the truck."
But The Dark Knight still offered some unique CG
challenges, especially since it was the first film
to shoot scenes with IMAX cameras as opposed to
using 35 millimeter and converting in post. Visual
effects supervisor Nick Davis spoke to StudioDaily
about his experience on the Batman flick, saying:
"It was important for the visual effects
to look as though they were shot on set.
[Nolan] didn't want the film to take
on a gimmicky visual-effects look."
Taking this route meant that Nolan's first
sequel to 2005's Batman Begins was "a difficult
movie to finish" as the visual effects had to be
rendered in a higher resolution than ever before.
When it came to creating the look for Harvey
"Two-Face" Dent, Nolan wanted to remove layers,
not add them. The VFX team had to digitally
remove the skin. Two-Face's exposed eyeball
had to be painstakingly animated by hand, as
were the subtle changes in muscle tension.
The biggest challenge Alfonso
Cuarón faced making his space
epic Gravity was achieving a realistic
lack of gravity on screen. Pulling it
off involved an intricate mixture
of practical and digital effects.
"Now there are flares, and there are mistakes,
as it were, but...no mistakes. It's all created."
The director talked to Space about the challenges
in getting the effects to look realistic, saying:
"It took a lot of education for the animators
to fully grasp that the usual laws of cause and
effect don't apply. In outer space,
there is no up, there is no down."
Co-stars Sandra Bullock and
George Clooney were advised
on their movements by real astronauts
before being hooked up to a series of
rigs created by Academy Award-winning
visual effects artist Neil Corbould.
It turns out that Bullock not only had to put up
with being suspended from wires most of the day,
there were electric shocks to contend
with, too. Corbould explained:
"There was a charge in there like
the static you feel underneath an
electricity substation. If you walked out then
touched someone, you'd get this massive shock."
It may not have been easy work for the actors,
but it worked out pretty well for Corbould,
who won his second Oscar for Gravity.
Arguably one of the most
influential films of all time,
The Matrix truly changed the landscape
of action movies, with its memorable
fight sequences becoming a benchmark for
stunt coordinators and VFX artists alike.
The term "bullet time" was coined for the epic
slow motion shots that the movie employed on the
regular, which were created by visual effects
guru John Gaeta. Gaeta old The New York Times:
"The directors wanted to emulate the stylization
found in Japanese animation. When we created
weather, fire and smoke, we wanted it to move
not realistically but impressionistically."
Raw footage released as an extra on
the DVD showed how bullet time was
achieved using an intricate setup of perfectly
positioned cameras and masses of green screen.
Whenever Peter Jackson's The Lord
of the Rings trilogy comes up,
the first thing most people mention is Andy
Serkis' brilliant motion capture performance,
though creating Gollum was just one of many
challenges Weta faced during the movies.
Practical solutions like miniature models
and forced perspective were used in places,
but the bulk of the visual effects
were achieved digitally. Even the
interior of Bilbo Baggins' hobbit hole
was computer generated for some shots.
Speaking to AWN, visual effects
supervisor Jim Rygiel revealed
that Return of the King was his
favorite of the three movies,
because of the monumental amount of work he and
his team put into the picture. He explained:
"Return of the King has more
shots than one and two combined,
it's like 1,450. It was mind-boggling to
figure out logistically how to do them all.
It's something you never think you could have
done and you did it, like climbing Mt. Everest."
Bill Nighy's character Davy Jones made his
first appearance in 2006's Dead Man's Chest,
although you may not have recognized the
actor under all those digital tentacles.
"I was once required to be a squid
man in a movie. I was an octopus guy."
"And I was perfectly happy watching
that. Because what are you going to
say? You don't like my squid? Well
then, you know...live with it."
Visual effects supervisor John Knoll was
able to develop a method that allowed Nighy
to be on set with his fellow actors instead of
filming separately in front of a green screen,
which in turn allowed him to
interact more believably and
deliver a far more genuine performance.
Knoll described the process to EW, saying:
"On a soundstage with 25 technicians
staring at Bill and nobody to play
off of, that quirkiness would all have
gotten ironed out. Somebody would say,
that gesture is 'too off' or 'too odd.' It could
have become a real sort of committee effort."
"My squid was world class.
My squid was an award-winning
squid because of the hundred men
and women who created my squid."
The post-credits scene in Pirates of the
Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales opened the
door for the return of supernatural sealord Davy
Jones, although Nighy had no part in it. In fact,
he had no idea his award-winning squid was even in
the movie until a taxi driver told him about it.
The season finales on Game of Thrones always
have a cinematic quality, thanks in part to
the digital wizardry of Pixomondo. Green screen
use is kept to a minimum where possible, but
bringing the creatures of George R. R. Martin's
world into the mix requires some top-notch CGI.
Pixomondo's VFX supervisor Sven Martin told
The Washington Post that one of their biggest
achievements has been making Daenerys' dragons
blend seamlessly with the world around them.
But all that magic doesn't happen until the dragon
scenes have been shot, so how does Emilia Clarke
connect with her fire-breathing babies? Green
puppets. The actress told Huffington Post.
"They have these amazing life-scale models
that we used for camera rehearsals for the
sake of the CGI people, and I got very attached
to them. [...] Fundamentally [they're] dolls,
I suppose. But it was nice to have something
physical that I could really picture in my mind."